こんにちははじめ社長です
親分
なんでもないですあったじゃあなんでもないですよ
はい
いないと声が聞こえないなおよげいたいと声が聞こえるんですけども
今親分のユニ着てるんですけども小屋分も今日まで忙しくドーハを編集してるわけです
よ
存在でですよ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っぜひあんにょん
まずはこれですまずはこちらの町屋5を2リアル超リアルなケメ子を3匹カンター
は雑魚の給仕さんいい
さあもヤ軍が驚かせますここまでは前回と同じですよね
まずはもう生キムして重い
持って
楽しみなんです
安心するんですあっそう
はい安静したところで超リアルな姉済みです
一例ですね
ときレスいます
ちょっとトップされうちにもたの知っているのでコンボでこれでと小さく手を振って
安心しているところにつけよう
て売ってる人と思いますあっちが便種を取っ切りされるということがわかっている
2段重ねでいこうと思います
かもよ
ん
の
弊社のおでかけここで旧車 ok でスキャン天地こそを
をやら親分
[音楽]
何しますかって
ua
ちょっと警戒しない電気とか10枚で大丈夫だしており電気とかマジ2月がタジタジ
ですねなんだ
もうデー山声をこれ大丈夫
お前もらいシャツです
相手より時は親分の下に来ては相当今経過者さですからもう多分にはこれシャベル動画
もいいと思っても水仙そうね
[音楽]
バイブの違
youtube 始めたきっかけって何ですか
youtube 考えたきっかけたなんですっ
た時にしたいですよ大丈夫です何もないですよ
はシャブのゆずも送りしましたここへまじかだいぶきっかけはビートボックスを高校生
の時にやってもうちょっとりっ
5 arr と box on うまいと見るために
youtube に出会って自分で投稿してみたのかっていうか
そう言い机ですね家良くないんしたんですか
なんっ
でもあの家具はずっと使いたいからいいもう
かおるぞい
何を言って何もただ30号ああもう
わー
[音楽]
amaran
えこっち姪っ子ねっ freak 名やこれ作られていると思ってちょっと
が住むから仕掛けてるぞい
[音楽]
すごくないですけどね
すごいえええ俺絶対防衛なんかあるんだと思うよ俺
創作ジョン回バッチリしかましたでも虚無的な
した
シェアの座関係で作った
じゃんけんっ概要をはじめしゃちょーチャンネルはいきましょう
言いますよ
すごい ole
[笑い]
ブービーレバーヌー
あるんですよ
おかしいなぁ
家メスのが物品や超ビックリしたよ本当にネズミよりもうちょっと研究が必要なだこれ
受けめちゃ良かったですけどねず熱としまって失敗でしたねす
また次回お会いしましょう第3弾を同時に入っ
同意
第3ダしていいですか
[音楽]
しています